[Musique]
dans son potager madame wang cueille de
la citronnelle
mais on a un box aux étapes seuil chase
home gansu chinois elle cultive sur ses
terres plus d'une trentaine de légumes
asiatiques
c'est la productrice du risen affres et
les cheveux
on est sur la terre des petits groupes à
frelighsburg au sud de montréal
stanislas mon copain il y fait les
légumes biologiques qui fait du sirop
d'érable et moi je fais légumes
asiatiques
une façon pour moi de me reconnecter
aussi avec mes origines
donc c'est des légumes des fois que moi
je cultive que j'ai pas nécessairement
grandi avec alors c'est intéressant de
les découvrir en même temps que les fait
découvrir aux autres
la culture d'aliments asiatique est
grandissante depuis quelques temps en
ontario ici c'est un marché que tente de
développer stefan jung avec des produits
comme le lui faut plus connu sous forme
d ponge que de légumes
c'est dans la famille des cucurbitacées
ça s'apparente un peu aux ou kinigi au
concombre et à l'intérieur on en cherche
qui ressemble au zoo qui nie mais qui
est plus sucrée est très aéré très
moelleuse un peu comme si on chrétiens
dans un nuage hors école du mizuna
c'était une verdure une moutarde douce
japonaise qui aiment tout amertume c'est
dans la famille du chou là c'est fait la
première coupe donc ils super tendres 4
c'est une vérité de bodoï
les feuilles sont plus foncée son rôle
sur le fun a ajouté dans les phares et
un petit goût de noisette ça tend plus
vers un peu un mix avant que les mineurs
et le botteur quand il gêne comme ça les
faits sont bien ta andré encore un petit
peu croquantes
c'est super bon donc ça c'est du troll
mon lait récoltés ce matin c'est comme
brocoli chinois puis tout se mange la
feuille et le bouton la tige
ça peut être mangée crue où ça peut être
cuits à la vapeur
deux minutes c'est vraiment bon c'est
secret chaque semaine elle sera à
montréal
c'est dans les marchés publics qu'elles
s'installent pour vendre tous ses
produits et toute la famille vient
mettre l'épaule à la roue
mon père henri bonjour de ma soeur
carlier et ma tante daniel weiss parce
que la communauté chinoise en général
c'est très important la famille comme le
projet quand même il y ait beaucoup à la
culture
alors je pense que ça sera ça nous
ratons
j'allais voir ce motard avec la salle sa
part veut aussi la lecture seule famille
de la rouquette mémoire maire de la
gemme lamentable mais j'ai jamais
déguster un verre de la route ainsi la
première fois qu'on met dans la panade
qui va donner aux 10-12
c'est surprenant la base mais est
finalement devient assez accro à ces
légumes là on découvre de nouvelles
recettes et d'univers savoir donc ceci
par être lassant quelqu'un qui est
moindrement curieux beaucoup les légumes
asiatiques mais j'aime beaucoup la
nourriture asiatique et donc je me suis
dit que ce serait intéressant de les
cuisiner chez nous stéphanie nous
envoient chaque semaine lettres avec le
nom des légumes et aussi des conseils
des suggestions de recettes des liens
connaître la personne qui est derrière
mes légumes connaître le lieu la
provenance pour moi salle une valeur qui
est vraiment supérieure
la chaîne d'épiceries guerre on a
récolté damas mais c'est la première
année que jean qu'une fille et thomas
mich expliqué qu'au moment de cuir
notre à bouillir
puis à la vapeur 6 4 la mission dit
rubens vraiment à faire découvrir les
légumes asiatiques dans les marchés
locaux et qui chaussent intéressante
dans cette démarche un peu ma famille la
communauté ou 6,5 les et puis donc l île
parc succès à transférer des
connaissances comment les cuisiner ces
légumes le de l'ufa enlever les corses
sinon c'est dur le légume et je
souhaitais d'abord je mis à part une
part qui a été basse airs et puis je
saute pas du chat joue tous ensemble
ma tante à faire beau plein donc c'est
une feuille des champions il ya du porc
avec des vermicelles de riz cru ou cuit
le légume ajoute aussi de la texture et
absorbe toutes les saveurs dans un plat
quelques erreurs qu'on a récolté cette
année afin de mizuno qui te tapes
douceur japonais
enfin le pesto au plh graines de
tournesol et huiles des façons simples
de varier les menus et de découvrir de
nouvelles saveurs comme avec cette
salade de shiso une feuille au goût de
cumin cannelle coriandre et à nice je
pense que je suis un des seuls
fermant sa spéciale vais là dedans
en culture bio je pense qu'il va falloir
qu'il ya d'autres maraîchers qui
s'intéresse aussi aux légumes asiatiques
parce que la demande et leurs pieds peu
plus grand